مصطفى 13 عاما من العمر ترك المدرسه منذ
اكثر من عام وجد نفسه معين لعائلته
مصطفى واحد من كثيرين يشكلون ظاهره عماله
الاطفال التي تنامت في العراق
[موسيقى]
قبل نحو ثمان سنوات
هم حاجاته مال المدرسه يعني
الطلاب بدي اشوفها من تلبس شو تسوي ما
عندي امكانيه كان يا ماكو قال يما راح
اشتغل
بالمدرسه العام قام يشتغلوا بالمدرسه
تعالي اتركها يعملوا البرلمان وعلى سني
قانون بشان العنف الاسري ومن فقراته
العنايه بالطفل وحقه في التعليم والرعايه
الصحيه وحضر عمل منهم دون سن القانوني
ومعالجه البطاله ومعالجه التسرب الدراسيه
هذه الاله الموجوده اللي هي الاقتصاديه
والفنيه اكيد راح تحد من هذه القضيه
نسبه من هم دون الثامنه عشر تصل الى 35%
في العراق اثنان في المئه منهم من الاطفال
العاملين وفق اخر احصائيه رسميه قبل نحو
ثلاث سنوات اما الان فيصعب تحديد عدد
الاطفال العاملين في الشوارع ومن هم دون
سن القانوني حسب وزاره العمل والشؤون
الاجتماعيه
قالوا انهم فقدوا احد الوالدين ومعظمهم
ايضا يفضلون العمل في الشارع او تعلم مهنه
لاعاله ذويهم على حساب العوده الى المدرسه
رغم حنينه من الشديد اليها
سامر يوسف الجزيره بغداد